人が生きるために必要なことをその一つとして周囲みんな上げられ人が出ることによっ
て
のそして体を休ませること言った新進党にリフレッシュすることが可能性は我々人類に
とって睡眠とは大切な大切な
大切なまあ
はいよ今度肇社長です皆さん寝てます家母杏
最近出てます雲林体が行うのです
今日ちょっと睡眠についてでございますみなさん寝るときにはどうやって寝てますか
その用いて布団で寝るか
ベッドで寝るという2パターンがになると思うんですけども敷布団でてもベッドんで寝
ても
共通するひとつの弱点がありますそれは何かを漏らしですまあ我々人間で高台者も
やはりこねー
出るわけですよだしますを出る理由だねひょっとしたらその
寝る前にトイレにか付いてると本皆さんもですよみんなニュートンなんですけどね年前
にトイレに行かずに出るとキョッとする皆さんもオーナーしをしてしまうかもしれない
ご出勤
ございますお話ししてしまうかもしれない恐怖とともに私たちいうは人類は今まで今
生活してきたわけだから後私は思いついてしまった相応なしする可能性が我々全員も
1%でもあるのだったらその1%にかけたいと思って私は今回終わらせしても大丈夫な
ペットを作ることを考えました
用意するのはこちら
ていません
うんうん
例えばフィットたくさん準備しましたこれなんですよと言いますと皆さんシャンターン
ということでしょうか
怖いんです観てね息を重ねてピラミッドにして1番目のマイガールにシャンパンを注い
でも壊れないんですよ綺麗に全部に入っている
今回とりわけてよしてこのバケツでお寄せ
このバケツの美女としてちゃんまずはたので今回の城イメージしているのはオーラスの
する可能性を合わせをしてもう
高圧をすぐれなきゃいいんですよそういうかとかお待ちをしてお勧めでの可決に行こう
液体が余って言って床につかないという12を出し車5台がベッドでこのバケツを使っ
て作っていこうと思いますパイズを引いてそんなにバケツバケツでベッドを作ってその
上からお話をしてもいろんな馬術に溜まっていくわけですが必ずおぼらしを床に村実
完璧な網羅し将来のペットができるだけだった
じゃあ行ってくるわー
4まずは行かねば月引いていきましょう yeah
現像が一致していくことによってもうねしか言わないけどどこでもオーラスしてもいい
ねベッドをつくります
くっ
できました完璧でございます上から見て絶対こぼれないんですねどこを見てもあの j
が見えてないので必ず動画の可決にたまります
大抵でまずは布団を引いていきましょうふと金別にもうねおぼらせしちゃってもいいん
です
洗えばいいですからけどねぷローリングは眠りが濡れちゃうとねか人が入ってないね
はず成りフローイングではイスはなのでちょっと布団だけ聞かせていただきます
関平実証ッで麻雀 p 7は今
ばかり言うと僕の言いたかったこれでもし上で僕がおもらししてる
もうそれでたさんって期待は全部この度鹿中月に入れるなぜ絶対したら濡れないんです
そして思わせしちゃってさまざまとリフトってネスってこんな流せばいいだけですね
これいないとやばいんじゃないこれきたっしょ
いやもうこれで枕をいたらもうもうこれでまたこれからモーゼルだけでしょって受け身
な大人も子どももおじいちゃんおばあちゃんもとしわれわれはどんどん
5おもらしするかわかりませんそんな時に一早く対処したいときぜひバケツレベルと
作ってみてはいかがでしょうか
みんな
lara
me
いっ
持っていた
あ
なんで
pr
いやでも持ちになったからいいけど